I think you know there's drama and so  the media loves drama so it's getting a  lot of attention but I'm sure they'll  work it out Katie Couric on the Kelly  and Michael  daytime debacle she spoke with a former  morning news anchor at the matrix Awards  honoring New York women in  communications Katie showed her support  for Kelly Ripa who will return to the  live desk Tuesday about a week after  co-host Michael Strahan announced he's  leaving the show for GMA I don't know  all the ins and outs I only know what I  read I think that probably Kelly should  have been included in the process making  a massive decision you know your partner  on air is critically important I like  them both and hopefully things will  smooth over and they'll both be able to  move forward with their incredible  careers because there's both Michael and  Kelly are enormous ly talented and I  really like them both